*can pops open*
*sips monster drink*
*teleported*
aeeeHHhh *relish*
SKRATTA DUUUUU FÖRLORAR DU - mannen!
You know the rules.
I don't have to explain them,
but I will do it anyway!
if you lass, you will loose.
skrat - förlor. very simple rules
You can begin this challenge right now by smashing that like button
Let's freakin do this guys
if this video hits a like
Then you are supporting a really bad cause
ha ha got you there didn't I?
Bet you thought I was gonna do something good for people.
No
All right good joke
*kawaii skratta*
Let's begin.  👏 Let's  👏 begin  👏 everybody.
oohhkayy
*pokemon music*
I've seen this!
hooRAyy
*pokemon battle theme*
*404*
Ok, ok. This is my face right now - not impressed. Although it is a very good edit, probably stolen by someone
All right, looks like so far so good. I'm still in it. I'm still -
#winninnnng
Heck yeah, guys. Can we keep this up? This is the furthest we've ever come
*table topples over and the cage breaks*
*slytherin makes cameo*
*RIP nagini*
*being-sucked-into-a-vortex music*
*heroic music*
snaaakee?
*humoring himself*
No, no, I did not laugh. I just humored myself. Okay had nothing to do with the video
I got so bored. I would think of other things. What was the snake's mission?
deh he heh ha
Alright, okay moving on
Host : The Scottish accent is famous for being difficult to understand but the Glaswegian accent can be even more difficult
Glasweigan.
Glasgow in norwegian = Glaswegian?
Host : I love the Glaswegian accent and I was wondering if you could teach me some local phrases
Man : well it's very hard to
bring anything to mind this is the
thing, it's only, it's alright if
yars are *Okay I lost it.
*I'm Scottish and having trouble understanding this*
*Hello to all the fellow Scottish fans*
*brofist from the caption army if you understand*
Host : hm?
Man : ya understand?
*horrific throat laugh*
Oh, you don't understand? *laughs*
Ouh my god, I thought I had it for a while. Is it a joke? Did he just have an aneurysm?
Man : well it's very hard to
Bring this to mind
Well I got, "well this is very hard to"...
*rewinding video in attempt to understand*
Bring out main dangus (Bring this to mind)
bring out, bring-a-main-daingus? (Bring this to mind)
brain-a-main-dangus!
BRING me a dingus!
that's what he's saying
It's only when its (rest of transcript lost)
*forgive the captions*
*I'm from the East of Scotland*
*It's a hella lot softer accents here*
sssOReh - sorry open your eyes
*what is he saying*
eeeeeeeeghhh
He hardly heard his eyes! See, it's not that hard
deu heh hhee
I understand okay, buncha IDIOTS
Peter Parker : That's a cute outfit
did your husband give it to you?
Actually, he did. He bought this for me on our 10-year anniversary. Not only is he my lover,
He's my best friend and my soul mate. I'm not ashamed of who I love nor
Should I be. For someone with strange abilities due to I assume
Accidental exposure to radioactive spider blood, you're not very tolerant of those different to yourself. You're on the wrong side of history
spider-man
*jumps*
*exhalation of nasal air which is a sign that a person has found something funny, but it is not funny enough to proceed with the action of making spontaneous sounds that indicate lively amusement*
I've seen this meme before but honestly Jack made it better. Well done. Can you believe disney posted this?
blatant
homophahhbiaah
Disgusting. What are they gonna do next? Fire Someone over some jokes?
pff
Butterfree : eee
Ash : butterfree
To be fair, you have to have a very high IQ to understand Pokemon. The humour is extremely subtle, and without a solid grasp of strategic battle moves most of the jokes will go over a typical viewer's head. There's also Ash's optimistic outlook, which is deftly woven into his characterisation- his personal philosophy draws heavily from the phrase "Gotta catch em all", for instance. The fans understand this stuff; they have the true intellectual of a nine year old to truly appreciate the depths of these jokes, to realise that they're not just funny- they say something deep about LIFE. As a consequence people who dislike Pokemon truly ARE idiots- of course they wouldn't appreciate, for instance,
the humour in Pikachu's existential catchphrase "Pika Pika" which itself is a cryptic reference to Ash's battle with Brock in the Pewter Gym. I'm smirking right now just imagining one of those addlepated simpletons scratching their heads in confusion as Satoshi Tajiri genius wit unfolds itself on their television screens. What fools.. how I pity them. 😂
And yes, by the way, i DO have a Butterfree tattoo. And no, you cannot see it. It's for the ladies' eyes only- and even then they have to demonstrate that they're within 5 IQ points of my own (preferably lower) beforehand. Nothin personnel kid 😎
NO
*weird laugh*
thATS IT?
200 thOUsand views?? yeeahhhhehe
WHAT IS THIS!?!?!
*snickers*
yeaaaaahhhh
Stupid short ones. What is yehh in Japanese? Hai? Google Translate. Yes. yeahh
E e
Japanese translation : A
Eeeh? Oh, it's like eeEHH?
so he's goin
EEeeEEUH?
nAN desu kaAh?
butterfree-san?
I bet they're not even half-weeb
whoever did the voice-acting
they shoulda asked ME
I woulda done a way better job than
yeeeyUH
choose your pewdiepie?
Wow!
(Pewds: Skratta Du Floura Du )
(MANNEN)
Real pewds : No. Untrue...
(Red pewds: My hair is astonishingly, incredibly, unbelivibly RED)
(Invisible pewds: player two)
Markiplier = red pewdiepie
(Jack screaming in the background)
Green pewdiepie = better than the real one!
hEY.
(yEs?)
What are you getting?
will make memes for food - SUB. very nice.
i dunno why i love this meme - the smash meme - its so good
*game music and SFX*
(Incoming Salt)
(The screams subsideee)
oh my god
-OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO-
jeesuss
dueeh heeh
*salt*
*zoom*
*subconscious unveiled*
*pure agony*
*very salt*
woooahw
mentos: the fresh-maker
*snicker*
i mean, I'D buy a mentos after that.
mentos, PLEASE sponsor me. i NEED sponsors.
Okay- if you're a company and like you just feel like you have too much money
hit me up
*aneurysm*
I'll boost you- have i told you guys abou-
But what advice would you give to kids like me who make youtube videos but dream about having a life creating films..
*lil lip smackie*
um I would say
(i'd say, well *in his head*)
(You got to just take a deep breath and give up)
*laugh track*
(No, the system is rigged against you your hard work and talent will not pay off)
(there was nothing to stand in our way, and we barely got here. You have no chance)
(deep fry)
*what he actually says* You're doing it, you know, you are making films there's this idea that like..
*2014 skratta*
👏 👏 👏
You're doing that hooray for you. You know, I'm sure he meant it
*mic breathes*
No contradiction. He's basically telling him he's already achieved his goal
*cheeto keyboard noises*
(press f to pay respects)
dEEP FRY
What id- auh... I feel like my brain is too slowed to have anything of value to say to these I
*he got sugma*
I always mix them up as well
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
or
(DEEP FRY EM)
It's a common thing to do and I completely understand
They're very....
They're very much the same thing
from now on to not get my videos to demonetized instead of saying the f-word
I will just go:
*platypus mating call*
I can't even do it as good, jeshush
(WERE ALL THATS LEFT)
(its up to us now)
*name*  get around put us on the *backside???*
*i cant really make this out*
(NOW NOW NOW)
*AGAIN barely hear*
*oooh watch this*
*tippy tappy *
*BIG TAPPY*
oh my god. god DAMMIT
*WOW*
THAT'S A LOT OF DAMAGE
Oh my god. That's how they won the war everybody. That's how they won the war : Flex tape. Confirmed.
Eeh
Yes *claps*
Yes *senpai reviews his meme*
jumps into battle
uhh my god
lets just jump into it
thats just too much nipples
JacksFilms! Great
*silent skratta*
huff
oouh
Good one.
*10/10 from senpai*
fine, grandayy, fine. What do you want a clap?
👏 That's all you gettin.
Okay, I've seen this video.
This is epic, okay.
jus wat-just watch
There's the- the most EPIC plot twist of all time
he goes "who made this burger?"
*nyeuh*
Who made this burger, dawg?
Who made this burger, man?!
I know you're hearing me!
*people in the background repeat in unison*
-Jason and mike made theirs
Jason you killin it man!
*approbation*
JAY SUNN
Jason, you're KILLIN it man
teheh
Casey : So let me start. I just wanna ask
What is this documentary?
Is- i don't know, i'll just ask directly- Is this a fluff piece to make people feel better about Logan Paul?
LP : YEAH
LP : Absolutely!
I mean yeah euhehah
*Logan glugs some water*
hoh my god
LP : Me siiting you- with you- right now...
LP : What what went wrong in my life that I thought that was a good idea
*Casey contemplates his life*
*and Logan's too*
oh my god this is awkward...
I wanna make it very clear.
I am the fastest, the biggest, the best, the greatest.
You understand?
*Logan, I don't think I understand this question*
I feel like this video doesn't even need editing to make it awkward
*?ex?cuse?me?*
When, when, the whole world hates you
*Regrettable™ *
I jus- I- I- made the conscious decision
I'm gonna- I'm gonna tase a dead rat
*weird vacant expression*
*pewds loses it*
LP : um
I mean, yeah *chuckle*
The ROCK : and world, when you look at this young man *ninja* he's a fighter.
*thinks if the picture is photoshopped*
*maybe it's not*
Doctor said he has uh-
He has uh-
Pewds : hehe ligma?
Rock : He has a few weeks to live
*meme cringe too much for senpai*
*savage*
*this is a perfect cringe reaction*
*perfection*
*pewds does the victory dance*
*suffocation*
*catches his breath*
*aww pewds, wish you would laugh more like this*
can we hit 500 thousand likes?
to help cure ligma?
look at this man
this man is suffering from a chronic illness
thats it for SKRATTA DUU FÖRLORAR DU
Did you laugh or did you lose?
if you lost - like. if you lin - like.
Subscribe if you haven't already. Hit that subscribe button
and hit that subscribe button
and maybe if you have the chance leave a like
Goodbye, everybody and goodbye. Goodbye